[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بعد اشهر من الترقب كتاب
الامير هاري المثير للجدل في الاسواق
وحاله الارتباك تتزايد في وسط العائله
الملكه حيث توجه القراء والمتحمسون الى
المكتبات للحصول على نسخه من المذكرات
التي تكشف تفاصيلها دقيقه عن العائله
المالكه البريطانيه صحيفه تلغراف قالت بان
طوابير الشراء على مذكرات الامير هاري لم
تكن على حسب التوقعاته حيث تفاجئ العاملون
في المكتبات بلندن بيقله الازدحام رغم ان
مذكرات الامير هاري واحده من اكثر
المذكرات المنتظره لهذا العام وفق
التلغراف فعدموا اقبال الجماهير عن شراء
المذكرات سببه تسريب الكثير من الكتاب بعد
ان تم طرحه للبيع عن طريق الخطا في
اسبانيا حيث كشفت التسريبات ان الامير
هاري يتعاطى مخدرات غير مشروعه عندما كان
شابا مع تفاصيل مؤثره عن تاثير وفاته
والدته عليه ف مشاركته في حرب يافغانستان
وهنا لفتستطلاعن اجرته يوغوف الى ان 64%
من البريطانيين لديهم صوره سلبيه عن هاري
في اقل تصنيف لها على الاطلاق بعد
التسريبات الخاصه بالمذكرات
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من لندن
المحاميه الدكتور امجد سلفيتي ومنظم كذلك
احمد مصطفى الكاتب الصحفي اهلا بكم الى
هذا الملف وهذا النقاش واسمحلي ان ابدا
معك يا استاذ احمد استاذ احمد ما الذي
يريده هذه سؤال يعاد يطرح من جديد قبل
الكتاب بعد الكتاب قبل التصريحات بعد
اللقاءات التلفزيونيه ما الذي يريده هل
يريد فقط او هدفه فقط
اخرى من وراء هذه التسريبات
الدفع المالي بالطبع ادافع مهم يعني هو
يحصل على اموال كثيره بالملايين سواء من
صفقه الكتابه ومن المقابلات او من الوثائق
التي بسنت فليكس لكن وهذا ايضا ربما
يتشارك في مع زوجته
البحث عن المال خاصه وانه ما يجرد من كثير
من الميزات التي يتمتع بها افراد العائله
الملكيه الماليه
لكن بالتاكيد هناك هدف اخر بالنسبه لهذه
اتصور انه همم الى حد كبير يريد الانتقامه
وهو بذلك همم ربما ينتقم ليس له نفسه فقط
ولكن لزوجته التي همم يشعر او هكذا تقول
ليها انها كانت همم شبه ملفوظه داخل
الاسره الملكه ولم يكن مقبولا بها على
اساس عنصري ربما بسبب لونها اصوله يعني
همم الفائده فقط ليس ولكن ميجان لها دور
كبير في لهذا بالتاكيد همم
في الواقع والثالث احمد البعض يقول بانه
لا لا تتحمله
هو نتاج لهذه الاسره هذه الاسره لديها
مشاكل كثيره لو لاحظها حتى اسم الكتاب ال-
ال- الاسبير
الاحتياطي او الاستبن همم هذه مشكله دائما
الاستبن في العائله المالكه في عائله
منصور حتى من قبل يعني وفاه الملكيه الذي
همم اختها الاميره كانت مشكله ايضا وكانت
ماده للصحافه ولا الوقت بسبب مشاكلها التي
تصل الى حد الفضائح احيانا الاميره
الملك الحالي همم
نفس المشكله بالنسبه لهاري همم في علاقته
او في وضعه مقارنه باخره ولي العهد الامير
ويلي اذا موجوده
هل سيقول بعضهم استاذ احمد لم يخرج احد
يعني همم سواءا بالنسبه لاخت اا الملكه
اليزابيث سواء بالنسبه سواء بالنسبه
لمختلف الشخصيات الاخرى التي تمت العائله
المالكه صحيح كانت هناك بعض الاخبار ولكن
ليس بالشكل الذي قدمه هاري وهنا سؤال
دكتور امجد هذه لما يتحدث عن هذه
التصريحات يقول بان لدي مشروع من البدايه
يقول هذا الكلام ومشروعي هو تغيير او فرز
تغيير تعامل مع وسائل الاعلام يجب ان يكون
هناك او تكون هناك صوره جديده اليه جديده
للتعامل مع وسائل الاعلام هل تعتقد بان
هذا هدفه الحقيقي هو بانه يعمل على تحقيق
ذلك فعلا
اعتقد هذا رايي الشخصي لا اعتقد ان هناك
من يشاركه بالعائله المالكه او بالمؤسسه
الحاكمه اجمالا هذا الراي هو تبع اسلوب
المشاهير في الولايات المتحده هذا اسلوب
ونمط غير متبع في بريطانيا بريطانيا مؤسسه
رزينه محافظه
العائله الحاكمه بها لا تلجا اعاده
الفقر بالعاده والي الاشهار وللاعلام والى
اخره ويستخدم اسلوب هجين على المجتمع
البريطاني ايضا ولذلك نرى ان التاييد لما
اقدم عليه الامير هاري تراجع كثيرا همم
لدرجه انه يكاد يعني يكون مهمش وهو فعلا
اصبح مهمش من المجتمع البريطاني وهو ايضا
مهندس لانه
بتسلسل الارثي للعرش والخامس وهو ربما
يعني يفتش على دور له
ولجا الى الاعلام من هذه انها تفجير هذه
القبله كما اسميتها الهجينه ل همم لفت
النظر الى هذا الى شخص وربما ايضا كما
اشار همم زميل الضيف همم الى استغلال
الوضع دي همم الحصول على ثروه ربما هو
بحاجه ارهابي بعد ان استثني من المخصصات
والامتيازات الملكيه يا استاذ احمد هل هذه
التصريحات زادت الامير هاري تهميشا
ويقول بعض اكثر من ذلك يقول بانه ظلم نفسه
بان هذه الرصاصه ارتدت عليه هي لم تضر
بعائلته هي لم تؤثر حتى في المجتمع
المجتمع دائما سيبقى في انتظار هذه
التسجيبات هكذا هي المجتمعات ليس فقط
المجتمع البريطاني ولكنها اضررت به هو
بدرجه اولى ما رايك
لا يمكن ايضا القول بانها لم تضر بسمعه
العائله الملكيه بالتاكيد هي تضر ولكن
العائله المالكه مشيا على ما انتاجته
الملك الراحله نزل الثاني الثانيه ان
تحاول همم ان تبقي كل هذا داخل العائله ان
لا تصح المجال
لمزيد من التغطيه الاعلاميه بالرد على ما
يصرح به او ما يسربه بعض افراد العائله
المالكه واظن ان مشكله ايه الان يعني ربما
كانت ضرر الاكبر الذي يعود عليه وعلى
زوجته هو ان ال- همم العائله الملكيه قصر
الملكي لم يرد على الاطلاق لا على تصريح
هذه السابقه في مقابلاته والوثائقيات ولا
على المقابلات للرجيم الكتاب ولا حتى على
ما ورد في الكتاب اذا كان اذا كان هاري
يقول كما ذكرتي وعلقته الكريم همم بانه
همم يريد ان يؤسس بطريقه اخرى في التعامل
مع الاعلانات والقصر
والفعل ان هو يعني لا يريد التعاطي مع
الانام لا يريد ان اوصل التغطيه همم هذا
يحدث هذا يضر فعلا بهاري او ما يريده حقا
وليس ما يقوله عن انه يريد ان يؤسس لشكل
من اشكال العلاقه بين الاخرى همم دكتور
امجد كيف ستنعكس هذه التصريحات وهذا الضرر
كيف سيتجلى على هاري بحسب قراءتك يعني همم
من النقاط التي قد يمكن همم نركز عليها
قادما وقد تضر بالشخص وبما سيرته وهو
بمستقبله
نعم اعتقد انه الامير هاري قد صنف نفسه
انه من عامه الشعب فعلا لا ينتمي لهذه
العائله المالكه اي انه فقد
الصفه الملكيه لدى الجمهور البريطاني لدى
الشعب البريطاني الان الشعب بريطاني يرى
هاري
كتاجر او ربما
كمرج الى حد كبير اا يستعمل يستعمل صفه
الملكيه للحصول على اموال والاهم من ذلك
انه لجا لكتابه هذا الكتاب ليه مهنيين
محترفين جدا
يعني اشباح تكتب له بمعنى او باخره هو فعل
يستعمل الاسلوب المشاهير والنجوم للحصول
على الاهتمام والنجوم اكثر هو يتبع اسلوب
وهما كان متاثرا كثيرا لزوجته
ولم ينتبه كثيرا الى همم انتمائه الاسره
عريقه في بريطانيا ولذلك اعتقد ان مكانته
لدى الجمهور البريطاني ان كانت عاطفيا او
رسميا تراجعت كثيرا ايضا هو حاول ان يستغل
اسم والدتك كثير من ال ال الفصول في
الكتاب تتناول معاناه لكنه نسي ان الجزء
الاخر من هذه الروايه الروايه معاناته
كطفل يتشارك معه بها ولي العهد وليام ولكن
وليام تصرف بهذا الموضوع بشكل رزين ورب-
ربما صمت ويليام وصمت
المؤسس المالكه العائله الملكه في
بريطانيا
بحجزات ايه ينفي روايه
هاري ويسلب منه المصداقيه ولذلك اعتقد هو
بالحقيقه اخذ مردود مالي لكن فقط كثير
كثير كثير من صفتهم الملكيه والانتماء
لعائله همم عريقه ملك في بريطانيا همم سيد
احمد هذه اللعبه هي ثلاثيه يقول البعض همم
فيها او اطراف الامير هاري العائله
المالكه والصحافه هاري يتغذى من الصحافه
ومن فضول الصحافه لترويش قصصه لاصدار
تصريحاته ولكن هل ستكون هذه العلاقه او س-
اا تعيش ديموما لان الصحافه كذلك والاعلاف
بريطانيا هو طرف لطالما كان لطرف المساند
للعائله المالكه
لا اتوقع ان يستمر الاعلام في الاهتمام
بالامير هاري كما كان من قبل اعتقد انه
كنا ذكر الكريم فقد الكثير الكثير من
المصداقيه حتى التعاطف الذي كان يحظى به
ربما لانه كان الاصغر حين توفيت والدته في
حادث النفق في باريس كان اصغر من ويليام
كان يخضع ببعض التعاطف انه طفل وانه تعرض
لصدمه والى اخره حتى هذا فقده هاري
بالكتاب وبالمقابلات التي اجراها
الوثائقيه وبالتالي لا اظن انه سيستفيد
كثيرا لا اظن ان الاعلان في بريطانيا
سيستمر في هذه التغطيه شكرا
لندن ايضا المحامي الدكتور امجد سلفيتي
شكرا لكما على المشاركه